Daniel Jackson and Jack O'Neill the most
iconic TV Duo of all time of all time
did you not see Atlantis McKay and
Shepard were way better
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
shut up Matt I absolutely love Atlantis
and I absolutely love Shepard and McKay
but the relationship between Shepherd
and McKay and the relationship between
Jack and Daniel is way different
and I love them both in different ways
but I I just prefer Jack and Daniel
slightly more and these are the reasons
why now I wholeheartedly believe that
the differences between Shepherd and
McKay and Jack and Daniel are very
different
the reasons why I think they're very
different is Jack and Dan's relationship
is a relationship built on trust it's
built on mutual respect whereas Shepard
and McKay their relationship is built on
Comedy it's built on sibling rivalry is
how I would describe Sheppard and McKay
they trying to one-up each other they're
trying to annoy each other and it works
really well on screen it's absolutely
fantastic to watch it's just not the
same relationship as Jack and Daniel you
see with Jack and Daniel their whole
relationship was formed and built wasn't
that very first mission to abados back
in the movie in 1994.
back when Kurt Russell and James Spader
played Jack and Daniel instead of
Richard Dean Anderson and Michael Shanks
that very mission was the solid
foundation that built their relationship
before that entire Mission Jack didn't
like Daniel he didn't like any
scientists because they were sniveling
and they were nerdy and he just didn't
get on with that kind of person but
after that mission he had a mutual
respect for Daniel and they become close
friends and that's something that stuck
with him throughout the entirety of the
10 seasons of Stargate they had that
mutual respect see the thing is with
Jack and Daniel is they're very
different people but they went through
something together that really connected
them and bonded them for life and
although they don't get along all the
time and they do differ on their
opinions quite a lot
the mutual respect is there and although
Daniel isn't part of the military and he
doesn't have the consequences of being
court-martialed if he disrespects you
know the authority of the military he
has that respect for Jack and I think
that speaks volumes because as a
civilian he cannot be punished he cannot
be
court-martialed or chucked in jail if he
does something out of line if anything
if if Daniel did anything out of line
Jack would be the one to be punished but
all that being said he has that freedom
and yet still respects Jack as if he was
a member of the military because he has
that that friendship with him and it is
a true friendship it's a friendship that
we see Blossom and it grows and it's the
relationship that we see really comes
ahead towards the end of the series
Daniel Jackson is an academic he thinks
with his head and he he acts with his
heart
Jack on the other hand is very direct
he's a military man he has been his
entire life
and sometimes they Clash
but they clash in a really genuine way
their on-screen presence and their
friendship is something that really
resonates and it's something that I
actually genuinely believe they've gone
through something spectacular they've
went through the gate they went to
aberdos and they defeated ra Together
Jack was there when he met his wife
and he was there when she was taken also
Daniel knows about Jack struggles in his
life he knows about his son and the fact
that his marriage broke down they've
shared moments with each other that you
wouldn't normally share with a colleague
and I think it's this sharing of
experiences and experiencing them
together that really makes their
relationship
see the thing is with Jack and Daniel no
matter what happens no matter what
villain it is they're trying to defeat
no matter what situations they find
themselves in they know they can trust
each other they know that they can count
on each other to have their backs in the
late seasons of sg1 where Jack O'Neal
was captured by ball and he was
continuously killed and resuscitated who
was it that came to Jack's side for
Comfort it was Daniel he was an ascended
being at this point and he was breaking
a ton of rules even just communicating
with Jack but he didn't care because
he's not the kind of person that really
cares about following the rules or
regulations he cares about people and he
really cares about Jack his friend in
yours be here for me damn straight
I'd have busted you out blown this Rat
Hole to hell and made sure that son of a
[ __ ] suffered the others would have
stopped you they'd have a hell of a
fight in their hands Bob would be dead I
don't think I'd stop there you're a
better man than that that's where you're
wrong in this episode Jack plays with
him to do something he says if he had
the powers that he he had he would do
something and he would do even more than
that and I think that's something that
really resonated with Daniel because
because like a few episodes later
Daniel Jackson Breaks the Rules and
tries to defeat Anubis
foreign
I don't think that would have happened
if you hadn't had that conversation with
Jack his friend
in pain in that moment said something
that really resonated with Daniel and
changed the course for Daniel in his
ascended State he was ultimately
cast out and he was no longer an
ascended being anymore
but at least he did something and he
learned something about himself at the
end of season 2 when sg1 returned after
destroying uh apophisen chlorell ships
Jack is basically thinking that his
friend Daniel has died he's torn up and
he's broken and the very moment that he
walks into the get room and he sees
Daniel you can see the relief on his
face he hugs Daniel and you can just see
it wash over him he's so relieved that
his friend
is still alive SG-1 there's someone
who'd like to see you
Daniel
[Music]
[Music]
base monkey
yeah there were so many amazing moments
like the NSG one but it's very hard to
compare Daniel and Jack to Shepherd and
McKay for things like that see I I look
at Shepherd and McKay's more of a
comedic Duro their on-screen chemistry
is more of sibling rivalry in my opinion
they try and a one-ar picture of and
they're trying to annoy each other and
it's really fun to watch I'm still
trying to understand how you thought it
was a good idea to test this device by
having someone throw you off a balcony
oh believe me that's not the first thing
we tried
I shot him but it doesn't feel
as genuine and as closely connected as
what Jack and Daniel are and that's
really the reason that I think Jack and
Daniel are more iconic and they are the
best duo for Stargate
I'll see you on Thursday for my video on
McKay and Shepard and now I think they
were just that little bit more
interesting than Daniel and Jack
here's the thing I want to know what you
think
what do you who do you like more do you
like Jack and Daniel do you like
Sheppard and McKay give me your reasons
why in the comment section down below
whilst you're down there hit like and if
you're new to the channel hit subscribe
press the Bell notification so you don't
miss a single video and consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching
I'll see you next week
[Music]